bom dia
bom eu quero compartilhar primeiro antes
de mais nada
qual foi a minha reação quando eu fui
convidada para participar do ped aqui do
dante eu registei esse momento pra
mostrar pra vocês qual é a sensação de
quem está aqui neste palco no momento em
que recebe este convite e foi mais ou
menos assim eu criei falei meu deus
e agora que proporção esse negócio tomou
mas logo assim como nosso amigo falou
macaco lá só que com um macaco apareceu
eu falei natália pensa bem respira fundo
vamos fazer esse negócio acontecer eu
falei como é que a gente consegue mudar
a vida financeira de 300 pessoas ou de 7
bilhões de pessoas através do ped em 15
minutos
eu pensei bem e cheguei à conclusão de
que em cinco segundos a minha vida mudou
então por que não em 15 minutos o da
vida de tanta gente
eu pensei em uma palavra uma palavra tão
pequena de três letras que é capaz de
mudar a vida de qualquer pessoa
muita gente acredita que essa palavra
tem uma conotação negativa mas eu
acredito que é o contrário essa palavra
a palavra não tá nem esquecida nem
ultimamente a palavra não eu tenho
percebido que muitos pais têm essa
dificuldade de usar essa palavra não eu
não entendo por que então eu vim contar
que hoje pra vocês como o não ou a minha
vida e como não me trouxe até aqui hoje
e o poder transformador do não gente
hashtag não é poder
depois ainda aqui colocam nas redes
sociais você tudo isso começou cerca
tinha mais um pouco tempo não tanto
assim ainda sou jovem muito só vocês
podem ver na verdade é tudo começou
quando eu tinha s cabelo nessa época é
meus pais nunca foram ricos nunca
tiveram a educação financeira de base e
tal
na escola sempre tem aquele grupinho
assim netpay aquela rica que é isso aqui
é aquilo e tinha menina rica no meu
grupo
a menina rica chegou pra gente falar
assim meu pai fez uma poupança para a
gente comprar um carro os 18 anos de
idade
eu tinha essa idade quando ouvi essa
frase aquilo chegou no meu cérebro com
efeito arrebatador
eu sempre fui meio fantástico mundo de
bob assim sabe tudo naquele exato
momento mas nem eu com esses cabelos no
meu conversível rodando alucinada pelas
ruas de são paulo como os cabelos não
ficará 90 desta forma não é verdade mas
não imaginava muito livre com aquele
carro 18 anos de idade
cheguei em casa sem ter à mesa com os
meus pais
e eis que fiz a pergunta fatídica pra
eles é eu tenho uma poupança
eu fiquei imaginando hoje é o meu pai
naquela época diante de mim sabendo a
resposta que viria a seguir
você já deve imaginar qual foi não claro
que não
meus pais não eu não tinha uma poupança
naquele momento eu comecei a pensar se
eu não tenho poupança também não tinha
mesada
eu queria tanto comprar aquele carro que
no fim das contas não significava só uma
questão financeira não era só uma
questão de dinheiro aquele carro
significa liberdade era tipo a
concretização máxima dos sucessos 18
anos e ter locais é incrível como é que
eu posso fazer isso
tipo esse carro era sonho de consumo
naquela época era o meu sonho de consumo
pela renda vermelha incrível não era
conversível bom foi bom eu tenho não tem
dinheiro já descobriu logo de cara que
poupança significava dinheiro e de vez
em quando eu ganhava 2 reais para o
lanche porque nem isso meu pai me dava
era de vez em quando dois reais
foi bom dois reais
eu nunca pensei no dinheiro assim tipo
uma nota de 2 reais e imaginados aqueles
dois reais ou 10 reais que fosse como um
pedaço do meu carro e aí começou aquele
dilema logo na infância dois reais ou o
resort em gordura do tião da cantina
por sorte eu pensava mais no meu carro
porque se eu tivesse comido gorduroso do
tião talvez já tivesse matéria entupida
aos 31 anos de idade
para minha sorte o carro falou mais alto
na minha cabeça e assim me tornei o
cofrinho de casa
de dois em dois reais e etc é muito cedo
comecei a criar essa mentalidade de
projeção fazia conta quanto eu voltei
daqui a um ano daqui a 2 etc
caló de contas a perceber que tudo o que
eu mais tinha é a tempo e que o tempo
relacionado ao dinheiro ainda que para
alguns parecesse pouco ao longo do tempo
ele se tornaria uma fortuna
eu passava finais de semana depois
quando já estava um pouco mais grande e
tal saidinha conheceu que era jornal eu
quero os classificados e aí comecei a
pensar qual era o carro que eu ia
conseguir comprar eu mantivesse aquela
minha disciplina de guardar um pouquinho
em pouquinho de dinheiro
descobri que eu poderia comprar um
burguês e e até meu carro conversível
que naquela época meu cabelo já estava
um pouco mais lisos
eu mesmo aprendi sozinha alisar o cabelo
porque afinal de contas quando você vai
ao cabeleireiro fazer escova você gasta
o que dinheiro
aliás esse foi o primeiro grande
investimento que eu consegui fazer
convenci meu pai eu não tinha o meu
carro mas eu convenci meu pai a comprar
uma escova com secador e desta forma eu
fiz um bem bolado melhor cada vez que
fizer secador semana 10 conta porque eu
vou de ti economizar 30 reais no salão
gente aprenda está o pm ó deus pipo mora
aí sim
enfim eu descobrir que aquele meu não
significou o meu carro porque ao
contrário de várias histórias que a
pessoa começa a contar eu fiz isso e
aquilo no fim e conseguiu não eu não
tenho essa história triste pra contar
por que aquele não significou o dinheiro
suficiente para comprar meu carro 18
anos de idade
acontece que eu não precisei comprar o
carro porque como era menina a gente
ser genial né pai mãe não queria
ter as filhas decidiram não guardava
dinheiro emprestado
quando precisava e tal eu descobri os 18
anos que minha madrinha tinha feito uma
carta de crédito pra mim de um consórcio
madrinha por algum motivo que não sei
até hoje é viciada em consórcios e ela
fez um consórcio quando eu tinha tipo
dez anos e foi contemplada quando eu
tinha 18 aí a questão de sorte mesmo
comprei meu carro não tinha vidro
elétrico não tinha entrado elétrica não
tinha limpador traseiro não tinha sim
mas por trazer não tinha rádio mas ele
era meu carro com o dinheiro que tinha
guardado todo aquele tempo eu fiz o meu
primeiro investimento e nunca mais parei
a partir do momento que comecei a
trabalhar pelo começo a trabalhar muito
cedo comecei como repórter não trabalhei
muito tempo entender e perceber que
tinha uma facilidade muito grande pra
guardar o meu dinheiro e fazer as coisas
que eram importantes para mim
sempre tive objetivos muito claros para
o futuro e nunca deixei de viver o
presente e aí com o passar do tempo
comecei a me senti meio que um
extraterrestre está vigente as pessoas
olhavam para mim o jeito estranho tipo o
que você comprou o apartamento à vista
aos 24 anos sem roubar sempre gente seu
pai
ah tá como assim elas achavam que eu era
muito esquisita que tinha alguma coisa
estranha naquela história e eu comecei a
me sentir uma estranha no ninho tipo tão
sozinha contestou neste palco e aquilo
começou a incomodar demais porque eu
pensava a gente porque né porque as
pessoas mesmo sabendo que tem que gastar
menos do que ganham continuam cometendo
esses erros absurdos e deixam de ter
aquilo que é mais importante para ter
coisas que não importam
cheguei a essa conclusão quando
contratei a minha faxineira tinha os
meus 24 anos alguém para cuidar da casa
e hoje ela contou pra mim natália olha
tá muito difícil pagar as contas o filme
porque acabei de comprar um tênis para a
minha filha
paguei 700 reais eu pagava 600 reais
para ela e falei o que leva uma pessoa a
gastar mais do que o próprio salário em
um único item
enfim em busca das respostas e que este
mote ao fazer 3 2 1 quando fala 3 você
fala
tá todo mundo comigo 32 o itabom muito
bem
é um momento de catarse porque eu fui
atrás dessas respostas na psicologia
econômica e tudo tem explicação dentro
do nosso cérebro qual essa explicação
seguinte o nosso cérebro gosta de tudo o
que é imediato o que é agora tudo dá
prazer agora eu amo isso
eu gosto do que é simples o que não me
faz pensar muito e de preferência que
aconteça hoje e uma coisa que pega
principalmente em relação ao dinheiro o
ser humano gosta de ter a ilusão de que
está tudo bem
além disso nã me vendo ali e quando
chega aqui nesse só uma marolinha
acontecer nada fica tudo bem é tsunami
vent pega você morrer
é assim que acontece com a vida
financeira a mesma coisa que ser humano
não gosta
ele não gosta de tomar decisões imagina
um bom agora três no futuro dessa droga
que agora quero que esse futuro que é
isso a gente não gosta de pensar no
longo prazo
isso dá uma confusão tremenda no nosso
cérebro ea gente também não gosta de não
ter principalmente de não pertencer já
ouviram falar naquela comportamento de
manada é que quando morrer vai atrás
todo mundo vai o que as pessoas gostam
de ir todos para o mesmo caminho ainda
que o destino seja o precipício porque
não sei o cérebro explica foi
inexplicável está tudo aí está tudo
explicado
beleza foi investigar a mente humana e
tal descobrir tudo isso que ótimo e o
que eu faço com essas informações na
verdade
de que adianta saber como é que funciona
os mecanismos cerebrais será que não tem
como mudar isso
eu fui atrás dessas outras respostas e
adivinhe eu descobrir a fórmula secreta
para a gente poder mudar nossa chave
tirar tudo aquilo que colocaram na nossa
cabeça entre zero e 12 anos de idade
quando a gente forma todas as nossas
crenças todas as nossas culturas
relacionadas ao dinheiro
vocês querem saber como é que a gente
muda tudo isso sim
ok o gent por grizzo seguinte
essa é a chave do sucesso que é natal do
ano dado de inter não é isso não é mesmo
descobrir que o que me fez tão diferente
das pessoas que estavam próximas a mim
foi a minha capacidade tão precoce de
ter metas de ter alvos de ter objetivos
claros e mais do que isso a minha força
interna que todos nós temos que eu chamo
de força t
só que não é o tema comum a gente vocês
podem ver um time grande que significa
um pisão e tesão quando digo que não tem
nada a ver com conotação sexual tesão é
aquilo que te move aquilo que tira da
cama aquilo que tira da procrastinação
do dia a dia você tiver metas mas não
tiver paixão por aquilo que está fazendo
você não quiser aquilo com muita vontade
não adianta não vai funcionar
e essa é a grande forma do sucesso e
tudo isso a gente resolver no esquema é
muito simples como esse quando você tem
metas você sabe quais são os seus
propósitos de vida quando você tem
propósito dos seus objetivos ficam mais
claros
você tem mais facilidade para enxergar
suas prioridades o que realmente é
importante para você quando você sabe o
que realmente é importante para você
você gasta menos tempo e menos dinheiro
com aquilo que não é importante sim a
gente que acontece quando você descobre
e se gasta menos tempo - dinheiro que
não é importante que acontece sob o
dinheiro e se você souber investir
cuidar do seu dinheiro você enriquece
é simples assim bom dia tudo isso
passaram se quase 20 anos desde o meu
primeiro não até que eu cheguei ao meu
segundo grande não eu era repórter da
rede record que realizei um grande sonho
que eu tinha aquele objetivo de ser
apresentadora e tal eu pensei poxa as
pessoas precisam saber disso tudo isso
que eu descobri estudando de forma
apaixonada com
muito tesão e é preciso mudar a vida das
pessoas
cheguei para o chá lindo maravilhoso o
chefe é o seguinte nós vamos mudar a
vida das pessoas vamos usar esta caixa
chamada televisão para fazer isso que
vamos fazer um reality onde eu sou muito
boa e mudar a vida das pessoas claro
ensina as pessoas a enriquecerem vou
pegar pessoas desesperadas endividadas e
transformá-las em poupadoras em quatro
semanas
ele falou uau que incrível pote isso no
papel natália que gênio que você é
beleza natália fala com todo um papel
duas semanas se passaram a dividir que
aconteceu
o meu segundo grande não da vida é não
era assim nesta manhã não eram não desse
tamanho eram muito grande porque não só
ele falou 'não natália não vamos fazer
como não natália você não vai fazer
outra pessoa para fazer a sua ideia
porque é muito naquele momento com
aquele não diante de mim e por isso a
força do não não é revolucionário foi
beleza ótimo vamos buscar o meu sim
porque eu criei um blog chamado me poupe
aonde a ideia era usar o entretenimento
e humor para transformar a vida das
pessoas de uma forma que elas nem
perceber sem que estavam aprendendo de
uma lavagem cerebral não contem isso pra
ninguém tá blog começou a fazer um certo
sucesso porque dentro de finanças é
muito difícil você falar e quebrar esse
paradigma de uma forma simples
no ano passado eu fiz um canal no
youtube onde usava os meus conhecimentos
todos aliados essa minha técnica
incrível de falar com a câmera e aí o
canal começou a ter uma certa relevância
em dezembro do ano passado recebi uma
proposta para ser patrocinada por uma
grande empresa e enfim eu pedi demissão
da rede record para poder realizar o meu
sonho é transformar a vida das pessoas
através do entretenimento financeiro e é
o que surgiu de tudo isso e destinam eu
gostaria de mostrar pra vocês agora
hoje preparei três dicas básicas para
você poder viver
e economizar você não precisa abrir mão
da vida para poder economizar esta é uma
lenda de gente preguiçosa que não quer
ter trabalho para poder economizar e
viver primeira coisa que você tem que
fazer para poder viver e economizar é
saber o que é importante é você pra mim
o carro importante futebol importante a
cerveja importantes droga é importante é
tão importante a falar falhou
brincadeira falhou isso aí me esquece
esse tipo de coisa que eu tinha ouvido
então gostaria de deixar essa
apresentação com uma pergunta pra que
vocês pensassem hoje mesmo por qual não
vocês vão ver hoje pensa a respeito
obrigado